so radical republican congresswoman  Lauren bobert or Beau bear depending on  your preference is now fear-mongering  about fentanyl or fentanyl as they like  to say in Halloween candy now I looked  very strongly I found no evidence that  this is really a concern and it reminds  me of that story that we always used to  be told oh there would be people who put  razor blades in apples and hand them out  to kids and the kids chew the razor  blade Not only was that improbable  because it would be really hard to do  but it seems that that was quite frankly  made up and these stories have certain  cachet and they self-replicate almost  like a virus and Lauren bobert is trying  it let's not let her do it and by the  way even if there was fentanyl in a  Halloween candy it would have nothing to  do with Joe Biden which is really the  point of her bringing it up